welcome back i'm so excited to talk to
our next guest because i have known her
more
than i would say 25 years i'm thinking
we were stepsisters in a movie called
ever after that's right
she's also been in two and a half men in
sweet home alabama
and i cannot wait to discuss also don't
look up with her because she's also in
that i mean what is she not doing
oh i know she's also keeping us on the
edge of our seats in one of the most
popular important shows out right now
and it's yellow jackets that's right
that's the show everybody's watching and
talking about take a look at this clip
[Applause]
what do you mean you killed someone like
you murdered someone i stabbed him and
now he's dead yeah
oh my gosh
the guy i thought was blackmailing us
[Music]
oh my god
i'm so excited please
[Applause]
oh my goodness
[Applause]
i am by the way you're on the set right
now of a hulu show that you're doing
called candy and that's what this look
is for
that's what this well that's what the
here is for it's it's in 1980 like
dorothy hamill kind of look
melanie
oh my god i mean we were in
the south of france
so young so fresh
so young
[Laughter]
and
we delivered the
rescue yourself
message which really changed my life
what about you i mean for me it was the
second movie i ever made and it kind of
remains a benchmark for joy for me
just because
you are such a joyful person angelica's
such a wonderful person getting to work
with the two of you and the amazing cast
of english actors
and just being in the south of france
and
just every day i was so excited to go to
work every day and it and it really does
remain just one of my happiest
experiences
[Applause]
of that just makes me so happy and
you're a mom now
yes i was interested to hear
about i think it was yellow jackets when
you were
you know you were wanting to spend time
with your kid
you were hesitant to take on the role
what was your reasoning i think like the
most important thing for me is to from
my daughter to absolutely no one there
for her at every moment
that she's just never questioning my
devotion on there she is with her cute
dad
so i'm reluctant to work i'm reluctant
to be away from her i i just
it's so scary for me and i also am
obsessed with her and i have been
working and it was exhausting and hard
and my agent said this offer came in you
know and i just was like i don't think i
can i don't think i can do it i'm too
tired i want to be with my child
and she said just read it and and i'll
you know pass for you and i read it and
i was like oh no
it's so good
you know when something's just
undeniable and
there's just nothing you can do i just
you know had to do it and i also thought
about it i think it's healthy for my
child to see me
working and passionate about something
and doing something i love i want that
for her future so i think it's good and
to do a show that's very fierce
when you're a mom also
there's something very empowering and
bitey and exciting about it and i can't
think of a show like yellow jackets i
mean oh my god
there is something about reclaiming your
own sort of inner beast yes that's
really empowering for me i sort of was
nervous to go back to work because i
thought oh am i going to be too tired is
it going to be so hard and then i just
found that the well of emotion
and things i had to draw on was so much
deeper because i had just
my life experience had just expanded
exponentially and i just was like oh my
gosh look at everything that's in here
now to bring out you are so good in it i
love you in this part
but then what's so crazy is i also will
not miss the opportunity to tell you
that one of the most profound
experiences i've also had watching don't
look up please tell me
that movie is so incredible melanie
you're so good in that too
oh gosh thank you i mean that you know
there are some jobs even after is like
this for me too where you just keep
waiting for the other shoe to drop is
that the expression you keep waiting for
something to go wrong and just nothing
does and don't look up was just one of
those experiences where i was like
wait this act is amazing this actor is
amazing everyone's kind the director is
awesome
i just it was just a really happy
happy happy time and i love that movie
i'm really proud of it i also need to
know
what is the meaning of life
and i got it in that scene
in don't look up and i can't stop
thinking about it and it has shifted my
perspective
so
that last supper scene and what is said
in that scene is something that has
stayed with me and given me a north star
of hope
and
contentedness that i was lacking in my
life and i thank you for that scene
because it has truly improved my quality
of life
leo actually improvised
and i couldn't hear him say it without
crying i think they had to cut around me
crying because i just
tears pouring down my face every time he
said we really did have it all
and
i just it's just so simple and so
profound yeah
i am sending you so much love thank you
for coming on this show and talking
about all the wonderful things that
you're up to that we're all on the feet
or on
oh my gosh thanks for having me i just
adore you it's made my day to see your
sweet face i love you so much melanie
linsky
yellowjackets is on showtime and don't
look up is on netflix we'll be right
back i love you
[Music]
you